situé entre les communes de senlis est
cerné le sentier des maréchaux est un
lieu de la vallée de chevreuse bien
connue des promeneurs cependant son
histoire est un peu moins cette carrière
permettant de fournir paris en pavés
jusqu'en 1930 était le lieu de travail
mais également de vie de nombreux
carrier habitants cerner ces temps par
son passé que son rapport à la terre que
ce lieu a touché jean govelle pour le
projet aux artistes le patrimoine du
parc naturel régional
j'ai tout de suite eu un tilt avec le
lieu qui était donc le le sentier
d'aider des maréchaux à cause de la
carrière de grès monsieur gentil très à
l'aise et je suis je
j'ai cherché à voir ce que je pourrais
faire là dedans je me suis lancé plus
tôt dans la réalisation de deux fûts
auquel je vais donner l'apparence de
dudu de la roche de l'aide de l'arbre 2d
d'éléments naturels tels qu'ils peuvent
être dans le dans la carrière il le
chemin sur lequel on va mettre ces
objets étaient le chemin qui était
emprunté deux fois par jour par les
carriers quand ils allaient travailler
quand il en revenait donc ça c'est
encore plus de sens je dirais de de
montrer un peu des témoignages des
histoires qui sont lieu de gens qui
arrivent et qui sont mariées ici qui
sont installés on fait des enfants
une migration c'est l'histoire d'une
migration d'une intégration pour
transcrire ses souvenirs j'en veux
façonner des objets sonores rappelant
l'ambiance qui pouvait régner dans ces
carrières au début du 20e siècle mais
également rendre hommage par différents
types de céramique
il y aura
deux types de décors il ya un décor qui
va figurer là les éléments
naturelles comme la roche sous les
arbres et caetera et des éléments qui
vont être des photos en fait qu'on va
faire fondre sur l'émail
pour moi ça marchera si les gens
s'approprient vraiment le
le ski ce qu'ils voient et ce qu'ils
entendent et si ça leur renvoie à
d'autres choses pourquoi pas un
imaginaire minérale mais aussi nature ou
ici plus méditatif avec le son c'est
autour de ça que les gens s'agrègent et
vont venir y greffer leur propre leurs
propres souvenirs
un travail avant tout sensorielle qui
cherchent donc à nous emmener dans une
époque un lieu une ambiance de façon
presque participative une installation
que vous pourrez découvrir du 6 octobre
au 30 décembre est ainsi ressentir toute
l'histoire de cette carrière